sie fliehen vor Krieg und Armut ihr Ziel
Europa ich war gezwungen mein Leben zu
riskieren um in Frieden leben und
arbeiten zu
können doch kaum noch ein Land will die
Flüchtlinge aufnehmen seit Jahren kann
die EU sich nicht auf eine gemin
migtionp übermen denn dies hier ist
nicht nur die Grenze Italiens sondern
die Grenze
Europas und dann sind da die die nicht
auf die Politik warten wollen die
Menschen retten
wollen ich verstehe dass es Gründe gibt
weshalb man will dass weniger Ausländer
nach Deutschland kommen oder so da kann
man drüber diskutieren aber es geht halt
einfach überhaupt nicht die ertrinken zu
lassen um dieses Ziel zu
erreichen
an Orten wie diesen weit entfernt von
Brüssel zeigt sich die Ohnmacht Europas
im Hafen von Syrakus Sizilien bereiten
sich 17 bezahlte und Z ehrenamtliche
Seenotretter auf ihren Einsatz vor wir
wollen uns vor Ort anschauen wie zeigt
sich die hilflose EU Migrationspolitik
auf dem Mittelmeer
dies ist ein Film über zivile
Seenotretter ich bestätige 120
Brote die boardklinik wird
vorbereitet ist zum ersten Mal dabei
ehrenamtlich
alles auf
Italienisch wahrscheinlich kann ich
nicht lesen aber vi haben die ja
so kann ich
leseni neuer Arbeitsort neues Team bei
vielen ist in den ersten Tagen
Anspannung zu spüren und die Frage was
kommt auf uns
zu 6 12 18 24 das
sind noch ist noch ganz weit weg für
mich deshalb ist es jetzt erstmal gut da
reinzukommen so gucken was wir haben mit
dem Team zu besprechen was wir alle so
für Ideen haben wie es wie wir es uns
vorstellen können B jetzt nicht und ich
guck es mir mal an doch die sind teilbar
in der Mitte die hebammer aus Berlin
betreut seit Jahren vor allem Schwangere
mit Fluchtgeschichte viele von ihnen
kamen übers Mittelmeer das Mittelmeer
ist so ein Zwischenschritt vom
Heimatland nach Europa und da passiert
sehr sehr viel und meistens sehr sehr
viel traumatische
Erlebnisse ist ein Grund warum ich hier
sein warum ich hier bin damit ich das
quasi mit erleben kann obwohl ich das
nie das gleiche fühlen kann wie die
Menschen die das natürlich körperlich
noch mal erleben und dann noch mal ganz
anders ansetzen kann als am Ende sondern
jetzt bin so im
Mittelteil die humanity One ist eins der
größten von rund 20 zivilen
seenotrettungsschiffen allerdings sind
immer nur einige wenige aktiv im Einsatz
das Schiff gehört der deutschen NGO SOS
humanity
der Weg ins Einsatzgebiet wird für
praktische Trainings
genutzt macht euch mit dem Boot vertraut
Dragos Nikol ist der Chef des such und
Rettungsteams der Rumäne war früher
Journalist und wurde dann zum
senotretter nachdem er über einen
Einsatz berichtet
hatte wir beginnen jetzt mit den
manövernüst
dich Rettungen war Dragos schon
dabei
Kontakt
okay down die Crew arbeitet mit zwei
Schnellboten den sogenannten Rips Bravo
und
Tango Nikolas von kame ist zum dritten
Mal bei einem Einsatz dabei
ehrenamtlich der Arzt aus Deutschland
leitet das kleinere ripteam
[Musik]
an meiner größten Sorgen ist dass es
halt einfach
so so overwhelming wird so kritische
Situation ist dass ich halt einfriere
und nicht mehr handlungsfähig bin und
ich versuche dem vorzubeugen indem ich
mir möglichst genau vorstelle was
passieren kann und halt das was ich dann
zu tun habe im Geiste schon schon zu tun
und
durchzugehen rund 9000 € kostet der
Einsatz täglich größtenteils Spenden
finanziert dieses Jahr erstmals auch
unterstützt mit rund 790 000€ vom
deutschen
stat wir haben alle eine Verantwortung
für D Menschen nicht in Seenot ertrinken
das ist schon immer meine Haltung aber
auch die Haltung der Europäischen Union
dennoch distanziert Scholz sich später
von der staatlichen Finanzierung in
Deutschland und ganz Europa wird darüber
weiter heftig diskutiert eine von der EU
organisierte Seenotrettung gibt es nicht
10 Tage Training liegen hinter der Crew
und viel Druck auf
ihnen ich möchte lieber dass wir
wirklich bereit sind wenn wir ankommen
den denn wenn wir eine Tragödie
durchleben nur weil wir nicht bereit
waren obwohl wir die Dinge unter
Kontrolle hätten haben können dann ist
das ein Problem auch für mich selbst
weil ich unsere Crew nicht ausreichend
trainiert habe lisa bogat ist als
menschenrechtsbeobachterin dabei sie
kennt die zivile Seenotrettung gut aus
dem Vorstand von SOS humanity dieses ist
ihr erster Einsatz vor Ort der NGO geht
es neben dem retten auch um ein
langfristiges Ziel wollen wir natürlich
auch
dokumentieren nicht nur wie wir selber
uns hier verhalten sondern auch wie
andere Akteure agieren es ist ja kein
Raum an Land wo Medien andere
Öffentlichkeit andere NGOs einfach so
hinkommen weil wir sind auf offenem
Wasser und der Zugang ist relativ
begrenzt genau und Teil unseres Mandats
ist es eben nicht nur zu retten und zu
schützen sondern auch zu bezeugen und
dann ist es soweit Ankunft im
rettungsgebiet ab kann es jederzeit
ernst werden und tatsächlich kommt
direkt ein Notruf über Funk
rein Flüchtlingsboot in Seenot viele
Menschen an Bord es ist unklar von wem
dieser Funkspruch kommt aber es stellt
sich heraus dass das betroffene Boot zu
weit weg ist per eil kommt ein weiterer
Notfall in Reichweite rein humanity one
nimmt Kurs auf gleichzeitig wird auf dem
topdeck rund um die Uhr Ausschau
gehalten das erfordert volle
Konzentration denn durch die Wellen sind
kleine Boote selbst in unmittelbarer
Nähe kaum zu
erkennen wenn ich ein Boot suche stelle
ich mir vor dass sich jemand auf dem
Boot befindet den ich kenne so sehr
möchte ich es
finden es ist immer noch sehr kraftvoll
ich erinnere mich an meine erste Rettung
als ich das Boot sah es wirklich da war
das war laublich manchmal geht mein Puls
immer noch
hoch im Laufe des Abends kommen Infos
über weitere offene seenotfälle rein auf
der Brücke versucht das Team den
Überblick zu
behalten
hilft dir das ja warum
nicht die sind sehr sehr dicht
beieinander das ist etwas
verwirrend das ist das
nächste und das ist das zweitnächste ja
5 Personen mit kaputtem
Motor diesem ist der Motor und da fahren
wir jetzt
hin gegen 22 Uhr ist es soweit das Boot
wird gesichtet auf das die humanity one
seit Mittag Kurs
nent los kommt schon ein bisschen
schneller es scheint ein kleines Boot zu
sein vielleicht 30 Leute aber vielleicht
auch
mehr
die Position des Bootes hat sich in den
letzten Stunden kaum verändert alles
spricht für einen kaputten
Motor wir sehen auch
nichts es ist genau vor
uns ich sehe es ganz klar ich fahre
schneller 172 km hat das Boot von der
lübischen Küste aus
zurückgelegt ungefähr 30 Personen Motor
kaputt hallo zusammen könnt ihr mich
hören sehr
gut ich spreche auch Englisch wir sind
hier um euch zu helfen
okay wir kommen aus Europa und sind hier
um euch zu
helfen aus Europa nicht aus libien das
ist wichtig denn die größte Sorge vieler
hier ist von der lübischen Küstenwache
zurückgeholt zu
werden wir haben Schwimmwesten für
Babys 3 Personen darunter eine Frau und
mehrere minderjährige sind in dem
Boot Bravo fährt mit 20 Personen zurück
zum Mutterschiff Tango nimmt
währenddessen die restlichen Personen an
Bord
stop Stopp Stopp nicht alle auf
einmal nach rund eineinhalb Stunden ist
die Rettung abgeschlossen laut
italienischem Gesetz müsste die humanity
one jetzt nach einer Rettung einen
sicheren Hafen
ansteuern ich hoffe einfach dass wir
noch weiterm könen also das W Wahnsinn
schon zurückfahren zu müssen ichau das
ist Stimmung so ein bisschen dämpft weil
einerseits ist super cool dass es jetzt
geklappt hat der ander Seite befürchtet
dass wir jetzt schon zurückfahren müssen
und genau das W eine riesige
Ressourcenverschwendung mit den
Geretteten werden wir später reden
können erst einmal sollen alle erst
versorgt
werden am Morgen dann ist klar die Crew
darf doch einen weiteren Seenotfall
Anfahren immer wieder erlaubt die
italienische rleitstelle was das Gesetz
verbietet gesucht wird nach einem grünen
Schlauchboot wir haben die Seenot
Rettungsleitstelle Rom gebeten weiter
nach dem Boot suchen zu dürfen da sonst
niemand hier ist um es zu
retten letzte Nacht nach D Stunden
Verhandlungen haben sie uns schließlich
erlaubt uns auf den Weg zu machen um es
zu
retten
doch zunächst taucht nur ein leeres
Holzboot
auf zuerst dachten wir das ist das Boot
aber es ist ein anderer Typ aus der
Entfernung konnte ich das nicht erkennen
vielleicht wurde es von jemandem
abgefangen wenig später kommt das
gesuchte vollbesetzte Schlauchboot in
Sicht da sind
Sie geradeaus
rund 189 000 Menschen haben in diesem
Jahr bisher versucht über die Zentrale
Mittelmeerroute nach Europa zu kommen
also vor allem aus Tunesien und Libyen
davon wurden etwa 53 000 abgefangen
2145 Menschen gelten als Tod bzw
vermisst
133 000 schafften es bis nach Europa
viele von ihnen aus Seenot
gerettet
wir suchen schon so lange nach euch Gott
sei Dank haben wir euch
gefunden in diesem Boot 31 Männer vor
allem aus Syrien sie sind seit fast Z
Tagen auf dem Wasser
unterwegs mein freundam erklärt euch
alles auf
Arabisch nicht seuglich
derktion vorhanden und es ist
überbesetzt okay
gut
okay kannst du dir vorstellen dass die
ohne jede Hilfe hier draußen waren das
ist
Wahnsinn
nachdem die geretteten an Bord sind hat
Bravo noch eine andere Aufgabe zu
erledigen könnt ihr uns die fallnummer
nennen die sollte in der E-Mail stehen
wenn das Boot leer ist wird es mit der
fallnummer markiert so sehen Flugzeuge
und andere Schiffe dass diese Menschen
gerettet
wurden los mach du nein hast du
Angst und es wird zerstört damit
Schlepper das Material nicht wieder
verwenden
können
sie kleben die manchmal ich habe schon
geflickte ziemlich beschissene Boote
gesehen dieses Messer ist scheiße nicht
zu
fassen ein Vorwurf an die Seenotretter
ist immer wieder sie selbst würden mit
ihrer Anwesenheit dafür sorgen dass noch
mehr Menschen die Flucht üb Meer
wagen was die NGOs betrifft wir wollen
sie nicht bekämpfen aber sie dürfen auch
nicht weiter wie ein Magnet irreguläre
Migranten
anziehen das ist einfach nur Polemik
dass Menschen aufs Mittelmeer gehen weil
sie gerettet werden ich meine guckt euch
die Bote an das ist lebensgefährlich und
keiner macht das weil er das Gefühl hat
dass
das
dass er da gerettet wird
wissenschaftlich ist keine der beiden
Positionen eindeutig zu belegen ob
Seenotrettung ein sogenannten pullfaktor
darstellt bleibt
strittig unter diesen 90 Menschen sind
rund zwei Drittel aus Syrien vor dem
Krieg geflohen die anderen kommen
mehrheitlich aus westafrikanischen
Ländern es sind vor alle Menschen die
vor Armut fliehen an Deck entwickelt
sich schnell eine Art provisorischer
Alltag eine Art Schwebezustand zwischen
den Tagen auf dem mittelme me und der
Ankunft in Europa wir lernen die
geretteten besser kennen und es wird
klar jede Fluchtgeschichte ist
individuell und doch stehen die kurzen
Einblicke stellvertretend für viele hier
ich habe in Syrien gelebt aber als ich
klein war verließen wir unser Land wegen
des Krieges wir gingen in den Libanon wo
ich mehr als 10 Jahre blieb doch die
wirtschaftliche Lage und die Situation
im Libanon sind sehr schlecht sogar das
Volk im Land selbst wandert aus weil die
Lage so schlecht ist
ich war noch sehr klein mit 11 Jahren
habe ich mein Land verlassen ich war
sehr klein aber in Kamerun konnte ich
nicht mehr zur Schule gehen und es war
einfach nicht gut den ganzen Tag zu
Hause zu
sein ich hätte sehr leicht kriminell
werden können aber das wollte ich
nicht die meisten wollen vor der Kamera
nur mit uns sprechen wenn wir ihre Namen
nicht nennen und ihr Gesicht nicht von
vorne zeigen zu groß ist die Angst vor
Konsequenzen etwa für Familienmitglieder
die noch in Syrien sind aber auch in
Europa drohen negative Folgen weshalb
wir die geflüchteten nur mit Ihrem
Einverständnis zeigen es kommt immer
wieder vor dass flüchtende Menschen
kriminalisiert werden und auch vor
Gericht gestellt und und verurteilt
werden wegen angeblichen
Menschenschmuggel Menschen die einfach
verdächtigt werden die Boote selber
gesteuert zu haben und eben mit
Schmugglern zu kooperieren und teilweise
wird dafür auch Material benutzt um
Ihnen das nachweisen zu können nur 33 km
entfernt von der zweiten Rettung dürfen
Bravo und Tango noch ein drittes mal
raus die italienischen Behörden haben
eine weitere Rettung
erlaubt lass das Baby
untenama 28 Personen sind an Bord
darunter fünf Frauen und fünf
Kinder das Boot hat Schlagseite und
schwankt
adult diese Rettung verläuft deutlich
angespannter als die ersten beiden die
Wellen machen es dem Team
schwer okay okay okay
se sch
sch
B ich hatte echt Angst zu viel
[Musik]
Wellengang
an Bord werden die geretteten
medizinisch versorgt und bekommen eine
Nummer zugeteilt die offizielle
Registrierung der Flüchtlinge wird erst
an Land
stattfinden drei Rettungen innerhalb von
knapp 19 Stunden alle in internationalen
Gewässern jetzt haben Crew und gerettete
1000 km Vorsicht D Tage bis nach Bari
dem von den italienischen Behörden
zugewiesenen sicheren Hafen immerhin ist
es nicht noch weiter im Norden aber wir
haben jetzt trotzdem noch mit jeder
E-Mail daran erinnert dass der Hafen zu
weit weg ist dass die Situation der
Überlebenden an Bord das auch nicht
erlaubt das herrscht sehr viel
Erschöpfung Italiens Regierungen
versuchen seit Jahren es den zivilen
Seenotrettern möglichst schwer zu machen
etwa durch die Zuweisung weit entfernter
Häfen dabei rettet die italienische
üstenwache wesentlich mehr Menschen aus
Seenot laut aktuellen Zahlen des
italienischen Innenministeriums gehen
nur rund 6% der Rettungen auf NGOs
zurück mehr als 90% werden von der
italienischen Küstenwache nach Italien
gebracht und mit denen steht Italien
alleine da lässt sie deshalb oft
unregistriert in andere Länder
weiterziehen die Folge eine ungesteuerte
Verteilung von Flüchtlingen in der EU
und verzweifelte
Appelle
wir en freiwiig Flüchtlinge aus Italien
aufzunehmen ingen
enggener
Motor immer wieder entstehen kleine
Momente der Nähe zwischen Crew und
geretteten et wenn z Schüler wir Namen
auf Arabisch Schreiben
lernt hier
war
schukran ist erstmal dabei zu sein wie
Menschen vom Boot auf unser Schiff
kommen ist natürlich schon bewegend wir
hatten auch Kinder und Frauen auch sehr
kleine Kinder dabei das ist schon
bewegen für uns alle
gewesen ische Team muss sich um
Verbrennungen Krätze Atemwegsinfektionen
oder folterverletzungen kümmern dabei
geht es oft nicht nur um die äußerlichen
Wunden wir stellen keine Fragen die
Menschen irgendwie in eine do Situation
bringen jeder darf so viel erzählen wie
er möchte oder auch nichts erzählen ist
genauso gut dann behandeln wir quasi nur
die Wunde ich das das das wenn man das
erlebt hat und darüber noch mal erzählt
und das wiedererlebt bei jeder Erzählung
dass das mit den Menschen viel mehr
Macht als mit mir die
zuhört Erfahrungen wie die von denen
unsige der geretteten berichten vor
allem aus
Libyen dies war mein dritter Versuch
über das Mittelmeer zu kommen die ersten
beiden Male wurde ich von der libischen
Küstenwache
verhaftet sie haben uns ins Gefängnis
gebracht dort bekamen wir nichts zu
essen sie schlugen uns jeden
Tag wir sollten unsere Familien anrufen
sie sollten Geld schicken damit sie uns
freiassen da ich weiß dass meine Familie
kein Geld hat sagte ich dass ich keine
Familie habe dass ich nicht weiß wen ich
anrufen
soll also schlugen sie mich die ganze
Zeit immer wieder aber Gott sei Dank
konnte ich beide Male
fliegen wir mussten drei Tage in einem
Lagerhaus bleiben bis die Schmuggler uns
in die Wüste rausbrachten vier Tage lang
ohne Essen und Trinken es gab Skorpione
und Schlangen es gab alles nach vier
Tagen brachten sie uns essen dann
verschwanden sie wieder für zwei
Tage er berichtet uns von seiner mit
Schleppern und libischen Milizen davon
wir er endlich
entkam aus Libyen dem Land das seit
Jahren Geld von der EU bekommt damit es
die Bedingungen für Flüchtlinge vor Ort
verbessert und damit es flüchtende auf
dem Weg nach Europa
aufffhälllt in diesem Sommer kam ein
Deal mit Tunesien
dazu wir werden mit Tunesien an einer
operativen Partnerschaft zur Bekämpfung
des schmuggelsar
ersereordinier der serettung verstärken
und wir haben vereinbart dass wir beim
grenzmanagement der Bekämpfung des
Schmuggels der Rückkehr und der
Beseitigung der Fluchtursachen
zusammenarbeiten werden unter voller
Einhaltung des
Völkerrechts der Zustand eines
Flüchtlings mit Nierenerkrankung
verschlechtert sich immer weiter die
italienische Küstenwache kommt zur
medizinischen Evakuierung des
Patienten die
Cre on hier in Sizilien an Land bringen
zu dürfen doch die humanity one muss
weiter Kurs auf Bari
halten mit dem Essen bekommen die
geretteten ihr aufgeladenes Handy zurück
oder können Ihr Handy zum Aufladen
abgeben hier auf dem Mittelmeer sucht
die Crew nach pragmatischen
währenddessen wird in Brüssel Berlin und
Rom wieder mal darüber gestritten ob
zivile Seenotrettung weiter
eingeschränkt werden sollte
Seenotrettung als Sinnbild für
ungewollte
Masseneinwanderung die Rettung soll
völlig unabhängig von der Nationalität
und vom Migrationsstatus stattfinden und
Fragen der Verteilung und der
asylprozesse etc sollten nicht vermischt
werden mit der Rettung und der Pflicht
zur Rettung allgemein und und diese
Debatte sollte nicht auf dem Rücken der
Seenotrettung ausgetragen
werden die Erfahrung hat gezeigt die
Tage bis zur Ankunft im sicheren Hafen
können lang werden der baberschop hat
Tradition auf dem Schiff zum
Zeitvertreib und für ein bisschen würde
für den ST in Europa Europa verbunden
mit großen
Hoffnungen die Hoffnung ist dass wir
unser Leben verbessern können Arbeit
finden und dass wir ein anständiges
menschliches Leben führen können ind dem
es keine Ungerechtigkeiten gibt und uns
niemand
schikaniert dass es Gesetze gibt die uns
schützen und nicht Gesetze die nur
diejenigen schützen die Geld
haben wenn ich an Europa denke dann
bedeutet das für mich mein Leben zu
verbessern und die Möglichkeit zu haben
in der Zukunft ein bedeutender Mann zu
werden und dann kommt Land in
Sicht Italien Europa in Bari legt die
humanity one an der hintersten Ecke des
Hafens
an das zieht sich so in die Länge das ja
wahnsinn da wird so die Geduld so auf
die Probe gestellt ne das ist
unglaublich selbst ich
auf die 90 geflüchteten wartet ein
Europa in dem sie vieler Orts nicht mehr
willkommen sind dass sie als Bedrohung
für den gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt
sieht wir sind an einer Grenze
angekommen unserer Leistungsfähigkeit
und jetzt besteht die Gefahr dass die
wunderbare Solidarität der Bevölkerung
die es bisher gab dass die schwindet
weil zu viele Probleme in Europas
Migrationspolitik ungelöst sind und wohl
auch erstmal bleiben
politisch ist das unmöglich auch in den
kommenden
Jahren bleib stark für den
kleinen die Crew bleibt an Bord kanapier
nichts mehr tun erleichtert sehr berührt
dankbar ganz viel komm
zusammen die Menschen die ja sehr sehr
stark sindes überlebt undestanden haben
werden ihren Weg alle gehen vielleicht
anders als geplant aber sie werden ihren
Weg gehen
egal wie viel Ungewissheit in Europa
wartet Menschen werden weiter fliehen
ihre Entschlossenheit trifft auf eine EU
die sich zerreibt zwischen Abschottung
und
Moral